[Music]
hello everyone thank you all for coming
to this session
sto defense-in-depth for modern
production environments good well today
what are we going to talk about today we
are going to learn about how Google
Cloud and sto gives you the tools to
help you secure your production
environment like Google so a lot of what
we are going to talk about today will be
based upon what we have learned over
decades at Google on how to implement
defense-in-depth and as part of this
we'll also talk about what is sto
security how does it play in the overall
security posture that you would like you
may want to implement and I am Samrat
ray I'm a product manager and Google
cloud working on various security
products including sto and with me as
Thole is the technical lead for sto
security a quick note for folks who
haven't seen this before if you have
questions there if you open up your app
you'll see a link for call during Q&A if
you post your question there we'll
answer as many as we can now you can
also post later or if there are too many
questions will answer them offline so
you can check it after the conference
like you can go back and check for
responses to your questions later
I will also be taking questions here in
the audience as well so talk a bit about
defense-in-depth
why now why do we need defense-in-depth
why is this such a burning topic at this
point in time so what's one of the
reasons why defense-in-depth is becoming
more important is because of some of the
emerging trends in application both
stack as well as infrastructure what
some of the trends that we see is that
option of containers and microservices
we see a rapid growth in an option of
both paradigms further we see that the
deploy
of these systems happen to be on public
cloud sometimes on multiple clouds and
hybrid lastly the adoption of micro
services also means that every service
can be built in a separate language so
we see a lot of heterogeneity in the
application stacks as well as in how
they're packaged and deployed and there
may be something that you might call a
service that's deployed on a VM
somewhere because it is a legacy system
and then you build your next generation
little micro service as you might call
it and that's deployed as a container in
a kubernetes environment so we see
heterogeneity across the boat and we
also see a lot of services that talk to
each other so as you can see there's a
bit of a communication sprawl that
happens within your network which is far
bigger than what used to be the case
when you had a clean three tier 3
three-tier sort of web app base solution
or if you had a legacy system so how
does this impact security so first of
all we saw that there was a lot of
connections right between the services
the collections also represent the
surface area of attack so there's a much
greater surface area of attack if your
perimeter is breached further as the
example here shows a compromised of a
shared service can can result in replay
attacks of identities of a whole lot of
other services so your shared service
can escalate the privilege that is
actually available to it so here in this
example we have a logging service which
you might think is not that security
critical but imagine if it was
compromised almost all your services are
authenticating to the logging service
and what we have seen another trend that
we have seen in the industry of late is
that option of arrest as a way to
communicate between services and the use
of bearer tokens like jot for example or
some opaque OAuth token but effectively
a bare token to authenticate as part of
the rest code so one of the challenges
of better token is that a bearer token
can be replayed by the recipient or
anyone else who is listening on the wire
so thus these credentials which you
present as tokens can be replayed by a
compromised service like the logging
service which can now suddenly pretend
to be serviced a right and start
accessing data from service B whereas it
for data which it should not have been
authorized to access so thus this
impersonation is a problem that we see
because of the you know increasing use
of bearer tokens as part of our modern
or deployments the last point is as I
mentioned your networks your network
infrastructures itself anyone who has
access to listen in on the network can
effectively steal all user credentials
therefore your route in network can
effectively become routine production
and that's an undesirable security
property so what are the principles of
defense-in-depth
that we aspire to build as part of our
infrastructure so the first is you do
create a secure network parameter your
parameter doesn't go away there is a
value to having a network parameter and
as Google we have our network parameter
which we obviously strongly defend but
once you have built your network
parameter and you've done all the
hardening of it you effectively then
assume that your parameter has been
breached
right right after you build it you
assume it has been breached and you
assume that the threat is inside your
parameter so so thus you now have every
service that needs to effectively
establish trust with any other service
that talks to it so in some sense at a
very logical high-level view every
service has its own firewall right so
you can think of them as micro
parameters and at this point in time
because you need to now monitor not just
the edge of your network you need to
have some central administration and
monitoring of every service endpoint
that exists within your network we have
this term as this posture has been
popularized as a term called zero trust
in the industry the term I believe
originated from an
analysts in Forrester but now has been
increasingly been adopted by a number of
security vendors effectively it's a way
of achieving defense-in-depth the key
principle behind it is that you have
peer-to-peer trust models right and you
don't trust your network by default
just because an entity happens to be
within your network doesn't mean it
should be trusted even if it has a valid
application level credentials and we
talked a bit about the difference
between various layers of identities
that inform a security posture like this
so we talked about creating a secure
perimeter and Google allows you to do so
on a cloud basis across all different
computational and service types so if
you have your traditional VMs we have
VPC networks and firewalls
we recently launched a kubernetes Indian
private clusters that allow you to have
build a parameter security for
containerized workloads running in
Google communities engine and one of the
products that is in private beta right
now is VPC service controls and VPC
service controls allows you to extend
this notion of parameter security to
fully manage services like Google cloud
storage or big query datasets for
example now having said that once you're
this is important to do one of the main
reasons to have an secure parameter is
to mitigate exfiltration risk because
you need some way to a some choke point
for you to control outbound
communication to the Internet and that's
one of the big value propositions of
having this but having done that you now
need to think about defense-in-depth
which this session is about so we are
going to start with two concepts that we
have adopted within Google right around
which or defense-in-depth postures built
the first is Bianca which is perhaps
been a little more popular and many of
you might have heard about it
and the other is application layer
transport security which is a paper that
we have written but it also informs some
of the key principles of our production
security so talking about Bianca Bianca
effectively is mainly applicable to a
human being like an employee accessing
sensitive data in a corporate
application for example right from their
laptop so one of the first things you
want to make sure is that you have a
strong identity that is phishing
resistant and a phishing resistant
authentication I think we've seen a few
articles flowed by recently saying none
of the Google employees have been fished
in in the last few years the second is
having well-managed devices which are a
part of your security posture and they
are actually the status of your device
actually informs access right having
well configured TLS to protect the data
in transit right having a policy engine
that can actually evaluate this multi
factors in order to decide what level of
risk that the request has and then grant
you access based upon the risk
assessment of their specific requests
and a policy enforcement point which
would typically be a reverse proxy on
your network edge that can calculate all
of these attributes and terminate the
TLS and then that then forwards it to
the systems that are then within your
network parameters that you created this
is Bianca and as I said it just because
your employee has a VPN and is able to
join the network every device that joins
your network via VPN should not have
equivalent privileges because your
devices may have different levels of
trust if you were to use a VPN software
to join in from a shared desktop in a
hotel it has very different security
properties then using a very well
managed desktop in your in your
corporate network and again your mobile
device may have a different security
posture right thus they're not all
equivalent and you need to have
application level understanding of the
device and the data being accessed right
just having an l3 understanding tells
you can you access this endpoint or not
but you may actually want to answer
questions like
if you are coming in from a mobile
device outside can you access your
compensation for example yes or no maybe
yes can you access the compensation of
your reports and their reports and so on
and so forth maybe the answer is no
because if you were to be senior enough
in your organization and you happen to
your mobile device is lost or
compromised we approach like that would
then result in the leak of the entire of
a large section of the employees their
compensations can be leaked as an
example right so these are sort of thus
you can see it requires an application
level understanding off the posture and
it's not just a network problem
application layer transport security so
application layer transport security is
the counterpart to what we do with
Bianca but is optimized for a service to
service in interactions in particular
this particular technology that we have
built has been optimized for Google's
production environment right it is based
upon the same notions of not trusting
the network by default but rather having
strong peer authentication and
encryption and transit just like me on
call right but and one of the key
principles again just like we talked
about before is having this notion of
being able to establish this trust at
the application layer and remove any
dependency on the security of the
network path right so you don't have
routing Network becoming routine
production very easily and lastly the
the way to implement this at scale right
and Google has hundreds of thousands of
services right millions of endpoints is
to be transparent from the application
code right that's how we can enforce
this by default using just policies so
how does the LTS work I'll go through
this fairly quickly but effectively ATS
consists of it's a it's a mutual
authentication and transport encryption
system that is developed by Google right
in some sense it is similar in concept
to MPLS or mutually authenticated TLS
right one of the key aspects of LTS is
that the ID it authenticates the
identities of the service
not the hosts right saying so instead of
authenticating the IP address it
authenticates identities that are bound
to services this trust model of
authenticating identities makes it easy
to replicate load balance and reschedule
micro services across hosts right so it
enables the agility of your sort of
authorization policies and the
resilience of your authorization
policies so the LTS relies on two
protocols there's a handshake protocol
right to establish a key and a record
protocol to send the protected RPC the
handshake protocol is a difficult man
based authenticated key exchange
protocol right it supports perfect
forward secrecy and session resumption
the record encryption the record
protocol encrypts and also indicates
network traffic using the protocol
secret that's been established through
the handshake protocol sorry so that's
great Google does this but how do you
implement something like this so one of
the principles we have within Google
Cloud one of the approaches that we are
taking is that we want to make these
concepts be accessible to our users both
in on Google cloud and as part of a
hybrid set up and towards that for
example the principles of beyond cob we
are incremental II building it into
products like the identity of a proxy
and VPC service controls and the
principles of application layer
Transport Security have been built into
sto
today we'll talk more about how we build
this into sto for a moment we will do a
very quick brief intro of what is this
do for those who are looking at this for
the first time given that this is
security talk I'm going to speed through
this section feel free to ask me
questions about at the end if you have
more so sto is an open services platform
you know that's built to manage service
in interactions on container and VM
based workloads so it is built to handle
this kind of a heterogeneity so it's not
just a kubernetes thing though it's
highly optimized to work with kubernetes
sto incorporates the principles and
learnings that we have
learn from securing Google's production
environment with technologies like LTS
and more well Google is one of the
founders and a significant contributor
contributor to l to sto there are other
major technology providers who have also
contributed to sto most notably lyft
who's who created the Envoy proxy that
we have adopted as part of the stos
technology stack so why should you care
about sto maybe you already have a bunch
of software that does similar things
that allows you to create TLS allows you
to observe traffic these are not new
concepts the main value of sto though is
that it's an integrated platform for a
broad set of service level network
functions so a couple of things one we
elevate the the principles to a service
level versus thinking of them at the
network level and B you get a single
integrated platform that you can use
both for traffic management for
observability like the latency graphs
that we showed in our keynote earlier as
well as for security right today we will
focus on policy driven security and how
is to implement that before we dive into
the actual security pieces it's good to
have a quick overview of the components
that make up sto
so sto itself has a control plane that
consists of three things the first is
pilot pilot is a control plane to
configure and push service communication
policies like for example service
discovery and even authorization
policies that run within the Envoy proxy
the second is mixer mixer is a pluggable
policy sorry pluggable provides
applicability interface for you to
integrate both destinations for
monitoring and metrics as well as policy
enforcement for policy providers
Citadel is a core part of sto security
and it enables you to configure mutual
TLS seamlessly across a vast set of
services and on a heterogeneous
infrastructure and it also provides
built-in sort of identity and credential
management so why do we use proxies
within sto mostly to normalize across
the heterogeneity right the proxies give
us this normalization layer and an
abstraction layer for us to be able to
have a homogeneous policy enforcement
and monitoring capability while behind
the proxy you can have different
languages different deployment models
and different RPC protocols for example
so how does sto enable you to secure
every service so Institue does three
simple concepts but three very powerful
capabilities it enables you to do MPLS
for authentication and encryption and it
allows you to do this without any
changes to your application code second
it allows you to authorize access based
on service identity or any channel
attribute right so thus sto allows you
to enables you to create policies that
allow you to define who can talk to whom
and then monitor those policies
centrally lastly if you are using modern
RPC protocols like rest or G RPC then
you can configure finer grained RPC
level access controls and we'll talk a
bit about what those are and these
access controls are what really provides
the rich capabilities that we leverage
within Google's production environment
for example so why do we support MPLS in
sto well it's policy driven encryption
and transit and as I said earlier with
no application changes so that is a
pretty powerful paradigm because it's
very complicated to write good TLS code
right and secure your keys and maintain
your certificates this is a lot of work
so that's great that's great
you but it's the obvious value one of
the key principles that we have within
Google's production environment which
actually is which is enabled to em TLS
is strong authentication this is
something that's not so obvious but it's
a very critical piece of the security
posture that we enable through sto so
the authentication model that we enable
why sto is that the peers are always
authenticated using non replayable
service identities and we make those
identities non replayable by binding
them to the TLS channel so you might
call them channel bound service
identities thus those identities cannot
be replayed by the recipient or anybody
who's trying to sniff on the wire right
because a they're encrypted on the wire
through TLS and be the recipient where
you actually terminate the Kahless does
not have the private keys in order to be
able to recreate all the search now to
be able to recreate the ident do sorry
to be able to replay the identities
these this a very critical piece here to
understand is that this does not
necessarily represent your application
level identity right so to take a very
concrete example if you have if your
service beaver to be a my sequel
database you would still have a my
sequel level identity that you propagate
which the my sequel database is using
for fine-grained authorization like
which table which row etcetera do you
have access to right that floats on top
as part of your call to my sequel right
what we are enforcing here is the notion
of a service such that even if you had
the valid my sequel credentials we want
to ensure that you are actually a
service that is authorized to talk to
this specific my sequel database so
service to service trust versus
application level trust so one of the
things we realized after we launched
this was that customers cannot go from
knowing TLS to all MPLS on day one the
reason is you mostly will have services
that have many clients some sometimes
you don't even realize the clients that
you have for a given service and you
cannot imagine that all the clients and
their clients and their clients all get
em enabled with MPLS on day one
so because of that we created this mode
within sto called permissive mode which
allows you to incrementally apply em TLS
to an existing service so for example
you can start with a service that
pertains to your most sensitive data and
then take the most sensitive client part
right about that you want to secure and
just secure that first right while still
allowing requests from other clients for
example a health check a service maybe
also accessing that service but you
don't need that to be MPLS enabled on
day one right but your health check
service doesn't break just because
you've secured your data path right and
this is a very powerful capability that
we have built into sto and would be
available as part of version 100 which
we're launching shortly once we have a
strongly authenticated identity service
identity we can now use that for
authorization and understand history
authorization you have to understand the
notion of a service a service is sort of
has a bit of a dual identity it's both a
networked identity as well as an
application identity and here identity I
don't mean in terms of actual
credentials but in terms of personas
right it's got a it can be thought of as
a networked entity or it can be thought
of as an application-level entity so a
service therefore spans the stack that
have shown here which is you can have a
service be understanding channel level
attributes like IP address right the
service identity that's on the TLS
channel or the kubernetes namespace for
example as part of the context in which
it is called it at the application level
the first thing it can understand is
your API or PC level artifacts for
protocols like HTTP or G RPC so for
example what's the URI what operation is
getting called on it and what are the
various claims that are encoded in a jot
token for example right so thus you can
use a service level authorization
policies like STS policy to do both what
traditional micro segmentation allowed
you to do by leveraging channel
attributes and saying who can talk to
whom just in pure terms of channel
attributes like namespaces for example
or just identities
right a key thing which is to enables
you to do is to trust that identity
right so you can actually do something
that's more natural to you as in with
service can talk to which verses which
namespace can talk to which write which
is little second order in direction of
what you're really trying to express
right this is more closer to the intent
that you want to express by using
identities but a very powerful thing
that is enabled through sto is to
combine this notion of a service
identity with elements that are
available to you at the API or the RPC
level so and then create a powerful
mechanism to determine a composite
policy like for example what operations
can be performed by whom and through
which path right let's take a concrete
example to understand such a policy
so the first Oh No so here's take here's
an example Joe here is an authorized
user and is a support engineer for
example who has access to PII right
but the only way he should have access
to PII which is the organization's
policy is by using a case tool right and
the case will then validate that Joe is
making an access with a proper case
identity for example there's really a
case a valid case right and the users
data that Joe is fetching is relevant to
that case right and this is a business
logic that's built into the case tool
the back end is configured to say Joe
has access to user data right
however Joe cannot directly access the
backend right in such a scenario Joe
then decides you know it's pretty
inconvenient for me to do this case tool
I need to do some research on some of
the a particular issue and look at it
across a bunch of users why don't I just
create my own little bi tool a dinky
little bi tool and then enable with it
with empty LS I obviously have access to
PII right on the back end and just use
the tool to then access to PR now this
while from a back-end perspective
application level perspective seems just
fine right Joe is authorized at the
application level to access PII but now
you're bypassing a tool that was meant
to implement a bunch of the
organization's policies right and that
should not be allowed
right so here's an example of a policy
file that not only checks that the user
on the chart belongs to a particular
role like reader so for example you
could substitute that by support for
example that has been authenticated
saved from your Active Directory system
and then encoded as a jot claim but it
also checks that that the service level
identity is actually the case tool right
and not the dinky little app that geo
created right now when you implement
such a policy it now ensures that you
have locked down the path for privileged
access to ensure that only an authorized
user can access it but very importantly
using just the right client right this
is a very powerful principle that is
enabled to protect highly sensitive PII
data or other kinds of sensitive data
from insider access and this was
something for example it's just not
possible through traditional micro
segmentation approach right micro
segmentation still enables you to
prevent you know lateral movements of
threads there are the benefits to doing
classic micro segmentation but here you
get benefits of both through mutual TLS
we explain how you can prevent lateral
movement of threats right to the
implementation of mutual TLS and now
with these kind of authorization
policies we show how you can protect
sensitive data from unauthorized insider
access lastly as I mentioned you need to
monitor your posture once you have
implementing policies at scale like this
at over a large number of services you
do need to have a consistent visibility
of security portion that's what is still
really enables you to do is take your
this everything that I described could
have been implemented within your
application logic right the reason to do
it in sto is one you free up your
developer so your developer can just
focus on business logic and it's mmm not
everyone is a security expert so they
can move very quickly without having to
learn all of these concepts but more
importantly the developer can use a
language of their choice they can use an
RPC protocol of the choice they can use
a deployment paradigm of their choice
right and you can move things around
right you can go from VM to containers
to cloud or back on Prem and while doing
so
as a Security Administration function
you still have a consistent visibility
of a security portion no matter what is
happening around the stack this allows
you to go through a whole sort of IT
transformation while maintaining a
security posture and your
defense-in-depth posture so this is
another very powerful paradigm that is -
enables you to sort of practice with
that it's time to take a look at how
this actually works in practice with
Asteria as it stands today for that I'll
invite Tao to walk you through a quick
demo thank you so hello everyone my name
is Holly so today I give you a demo
about a sea of security features and so
the agenda includes do you want to use
mine instead
okay okay so the agenda includes that
four items the first one is a policy
based M TOS authentication the second
one is a identity based authorization
the third one is about end-user
identity verification - the third one
the fourth one is a monitoring and I'm
gonna use a pretty simple example to
walk you through what is your security
can do for you let's say you are
developing this simple app this one has
a front end and have a back end so the
end user called the front end and front
end will get the data from back end and
send it back to any user so this is
pretty simple but in this model you can
see currently there's no traffic
encryption and no access control and no
monitoring so what we can do this once
you install East deal East you can
handle all the security stuff for you so
you don't have to spend a lot of effort
to implement it security code and he
still will handle this feature for you
you can have you can focus on your own
business logic so as you can see here
once we deploy sto gives you the sidecar
proxy
that that deployed right next to your
service each of your service you have a
nice tight car and this proxy will
intercept all the incoming and outgoing
traffic and besides that he still has an
ingress part so this one is also and boy
based the proxy and all incoming traffic
will go through the ingress and then go
to the our front end so this mother has
a problem let's say somebody hacking to
your network within your own network so
within your network so the hacker can
talk to the backend even when you're
back and has some like a PRI information
so how do we solve that
so within this you you can force mg of
us you can once you enforce mutuality
mutual TLS on your front end and the
back end so because the client so in
that way the client needs to provide a
valid certificate so since this hacker
was in there the only hack into the
network but you're not having another
privilege to join the match which means
you don't have a proxy that will show
you that this attack will be stopped and
this is about this about what we meet UT
else can do of course Nisha TS can
encrypt the traffic for you so sometimes
we feel like the beauty of it sonali
enough we need some access control
imagine you have a front end and the
back end but but normally you can have
like your hand deliver or thousand other
apps for example in samurais example you
might have a login apps right
see this one if this one got compromised
this logging can belongs to your totally
different Department and it's not
supposed to call the back end but
because this one has a proxy so this one
could get a key search from like our
Citadel our control plan so change so
change that are this logging once it's a
compromise so the bad guy can can hack
into the login system and we call the
backend to call you to get your
sensitive information like a credit card
information so what we can do this we
just deploy each do access control on
our back-end so once we have this one
deployed we'll specify that only
and connects as a back end so that the
locking even you have the valid key
search you cannot talk to the back end
okay so we're talking about two inside
the attackers and we haven't really
focus on the end users so right now from
any user and the user has not provided
any token yet so what if we have a
malicious guy said outside with the
network and they're trying to do the
same thing as our normal guys do so they
will try to call our front end so the
trafficking will still go through
so chances are you can you can also
implement your own like a end user
validation system but it is to provide
this for you so you don't have to really
worry about it and what we can do I'm
going to show you is will we enforce
this end user token check at our front
end so the hackers cannot cannot talk to
the front end anymore
because you don't have a valid token but
for our normal person you can ask her
out for example our atomy you can
actually have the access you have access
to the end user token for example the
java token so you are able to access the
the network and the last one I'm going
to show you about the the modern stuff
so let's look at the demo cue a switch
to turn on please okay so let's look at
it I already have this demo set it up so
you can look it here I have a product
page which is our front end and there
were details which is our back end each
of them already have a sidecar because
we have seen two containers and I have a
easier control and deployed already so
right now there's no in steel security
feature applied yet so if we look at
this page this our online webpage from
external you can access you can't get to
this webpage
but you can see here we have some
sensitive information like a credit card
information and as I mentioned the first
thing I'm going to show you is if
somebody hacking into your network for
example this is a gke note this one is
within the network so if someone hack
into the network so
they can do so what this guy can do it
will call our back-end this is the IP
address of our back-end so we can call
our back-end to gather sensitive
information for example you can see the
credit card here she's here okay so what
we can do this we apply we apply mtrs
policy by the way this this case just my
alias for Cuba kado
let's so right now the policy is
deployed let's look at that policy first
so this policy defines enforced MT OS on
default namespace so our front-end and
the backend post-deploy don t for
namespace so once you deploy this page
you will see that the front end and back
and post required appear to present a
valid cert so that means for this case
if you're within the network but you
don't present a key cert you will see
you can pretend the client cert you see
the traffic they'll rejected and from
our normal web page is always work
speakers from ingress and the to front
and the back and everyone has proxy okay
so this is a MT OS the second thing I
want to show you is about the access
control so let's say we have I mentioned
we have a login system and I actually
called it a sleep part in my unite case
so we have a part here this one had a
sidecar deployed and you can assure I'm
gonna show you that when I assess edge
into this part I can talk to the backend
so you can see this is the credit card
information shows up here even you have
a meteors because this was this guy also
have a client certificate so you cannot
prevent this and what I can do is I will
apply this access policy now let's take
a look at the policy so the policy what
this policy does it
it enabled our back on the default
namespace right here t-phone namespace
by the way our back is a role based
access control so easy to use that are
back to do the access control and this
one defines our back on our default
namespace which is our front-end and
back-end so let's look at the actual
service rows we have two rows first one
it's about the first the service role is
about the the from the product page
which is our front-end so this one
defines the get permission to the
front-end and you can see the user is a
star which means right now in this
policy everyone can have access to the
front-end of course you can set more
stricter policy but more interesting
thing is here so if you look at here
another services role defines the cache
permission to the details to the backend
and how do we who do we bind this
permission to you can look at here this
is the user this is out product page
without front-end so once we deploy this
policy you can see that only front-end
can access back-end but everything else
even you have a client you even you have
a client certificate you cannot access
it anymore so let's take a look so this
is the one I tried before so once we
take a look at this one you will see
there should be some error yeah for
Street forbidden right
so once we have this you can see even
you have client certificate you cannot
access it because you don't have the we
set the access control and from here
since I started setup the access control
properly so the front-end can access it
so this page still there okay so this is
about MTO us and the control access
control to the third one I want to show
you is about any user so the end user is
sometimes as I mentioned we want to we
want to devise some policies such that
the end user needs to present me some
valid token otherwise I'm going to stop
you so if you look at this example right
now from this web page the and use it
the
does not provide any token yet but this
havoc can still go through so I'm gonna
enforce some policy let's take a look
so I deploy this jot authentication
policy let's take a look at this policy
first so this policy applies to our
product page which is out front it and
it required the pier to present a
certificate which it appears at Misha
tos and a region
besides the pier we'll also want to
specify the origin of this color
we'll need to we require the chart so
this is the easier of the jot and this
is a word you can fetch the public key
to validate this chart okay so once we
specify this let's look at this page the
part of the policy may take a while to
propagate so yeah so you can see this
original application failed and because
this one doesn't have a valid token and
what I can do is I prepare a valid token
actually right here beforehand and let's
see from this page this one still works
because this guy present a valid token
and this is about any user verification
the last one I wanna show you in the
demo is about the monitoring so II still
integrate with the Garifuna
which is the which is the open source
tools that you fer you to modify to to
monitor the traffic so from here as you
can see here we have a different service
you can select a different service and
you can select the different stuff and
in the the x-axis is a time and the
y-axis is a QPS so you can see here this
is a red line this red line means the T
for production page default 200 so this
one is before we enforce an TOS so you
can see this is the first traffic so
after we enforce em TOS you can see this
the product page default 200 m TOS so
from here all the green lines means it's
something that is the traffic generated
after we deploy
MTO
okay and besides we also have them
purple lines the purple eyes means we
have four ones that's because we call
this one the travel girl rejected
alright so that's pretty much about the
demo part we talk about em TOS we talked
about access control we talked about any
user verification we talked about the
monitoring and the last thing this is a
pretty much about the demo and switch
back to the slides please
okay so beside that I want you to have
more stuff becoming as you can see here
for from we have a HDL 1.0 coming pretty
quick and that will have like after a
year to work and we have a manatee still
on gke that would provide the best thing
easier user experience across all the
cloud platform and another thing is
besides this talk we have other talks
about the container security within this
next event so stay tuned thank you
[Applause]
[Music]